okay let's see what's crackin now a job
just there oh hello Lily
I could he is that actually now Clem
times hungry is booked ok ok ok ok
anything else here don't forget that
hey there this is glen and I'm kind of
in a jam here a little girl if you're
there can you put your daddy on the
phone art on the doggy or whatever [ __ ]
this is lee what's up so I'm done in 10
muttering and well I'm stuck stuck yeah
i saw chance to get some supplies for
the group a bunch of what's up glades
trapped down at the motor unit they
claim they'll talk it over and send a
group to come get you all right awesome
I'll [ __ ] tight children sounds good
thanks animal hold onto this until we
get Glenn Beck okay I'll take good care
of it what do you think I think Doug's
that great around some bees you got your
family here I'll take Carly and her dead
I down to the motor and get glinted get
back here as fast as I can that's what
you want to do somebody's got to yeah
i'm in good doesn't sound too bad there
right now let me know as soon as you
want to head out I could use a jog ok
are we getting those meds they'll like
okay let me get this energy bar real
quick yes yes I like that energy bar all
right let's give this [ __ ] that out you
are snack lunch but here you go thank
you of course
okay i give her another water
it's not much but here you sure yeah
you're under quite a bit of stress
thanks that's really sweet don't mention
don't mention it sucka we gotta get this
guy's harpoons relieved do good this guy
is not there too hot oh [ __ ] we can just
like feat everyone here we're just
giving out candy Oh [ __ ] candy man
this guy does not one candy after sure
he needs like real [ __ ] like an EpiPen
we can't let anything happen to ducky I
know hun it's all melted now yeah yes
okay
it's not much but here for the board oh
thanks Lee he appreciates it that's
sweetly
okay thank you sure clippings
photographs no I need like we just need
to get better at Fort Lauderdale we'll
do our damnedest photographs Hey look at
luck yet oh it's good cardboard
okay duck duck now down to carry now now
now Sam a newspaper examine
third box
the [ __ ] where the [ __ ] is they get me
out talking talking people now
how's he doing I'm not sure I got your
name its Lee Lily my dad's Larry sucking
hot though I was just doing what I had
to earlier everyone was how his heart's
acting up again and I'm powerless to do
anything and that violence before with
my dad it didn't help oh [ __ ]
I'm gonna get back to him so it's good
try to get some rest huh how can I would
those things out there Hayley may be
punching him wasn't such a good idea no
what were worth plans says the guy who
didn't get punched in the mouth anyway
we cat and I appreciate your support
Thank You Lee I'm stuck to her he's okay
[ __ ] up person a turkey lucky as hell
nobody got nabbed on the way in here
move cute how is she doing
she's good she's a tough one right there
thank you just a little girl ken were
you saying Lee she spent days surviving
on her own that's right not just any
little girl can do that what's the plan
hang tight I suppose seems pretty
dangerous out there so we ought to wait
for things to clear up yeah its entirety
was from here in Macon that's right
where are they should we go looking for
them
they own this place they're gone Oh
sweetie cat they were good people this
guy like not gonna learn our yeah Lee
you got a second sure
back on Herschel's farm yeah
we didn't even try to save him that
blood is on our hands you know I love to
wear it
it happened pretty fast i guess but i
can't stop seeing him in my head we
can't kill ourselves so we killed that
boy we could have saved him together we
did what we could man [ __ ] a safe dear
boy dad we didn't make a choice of
kilrogg you think you do when you look
back on it but in a moment when things
are really out of control you know I
have a good choice
I guess it's guess [ __ ] why
try to let it go
where the [ __ ] target that office
kidding maybe Glenn has it
nothing hand up nothing here what's that
no I'm sorry to hear your loved one was
eaten by the Living Dead cards very
funny
oh yes that's Hanson all day isn't it
heard or seen anything nothing luckily
wanna step outside have a look around
yeah I'm not suicidal yet know the gate
out there is closed we can hang out in
front of the store and be fine oh ok
sure seemed in that case I look around
cool and we'll keep it down don't need
to bring them back this way with any
unnecessary noises it's very true very
true oh oh excuse me ma'am man what
placed them aside oh god this is
horrible it's like a radio shack on the
closing today yes must eat far as i can
tell they eat you and whatever's left
comes back is one of them it might be
more than a couple days before also
articulate okay i think so too we better
keep it down out of here
let's see the drugstore nothing else
around here that break down Jeffery's
unbrick the kid reach that brick I mean
you can't reach that brick
any idea where the pharmacy keys might
be he's searched high and low inside
before he has about here and one on the
old couple we took out of the office oh
that was the parent came I'm fine if the
keys are in a drugstore think they could
be out here now live in a world where
getting up and walking
right generates a break I need that big
you can do anything with this you gonna
break
Oh way he used to fiddle around and
stuff like that when I was a kid but
he's not much to do with it now
robots you're a strange guy I know
but the [ __ ] that
I gotta figure out a way to get that Oh
what the [ __ ] hey man what are you doing
we can't even think about going out
there and unless the keys are out there
for sure
naschet we're gone out there hey man
what are you doing we can't even think
about going out their endless the keys
are out there for sure it's a
combination lock that's a hasty
fortification job over there yeah didn't
work
and
that guy over there is the keys
how can you be sure
I found this in the office Oh shet that
boy in the photo worked here the keys
being on him is as good at that is
that's [ __ ] brother oh that is [ __ ]
doggy ground get up there and get them
you wouldn't need long right
just a few seconds
maybe there's a way to distract them and
buy you some time
oh yeah genius genius
think you can do anything with this
no I could do what's that
let's do cuz to like I with those TVs
across the street but do I guys Power
Stone
you can just do that I memorized all the
codes knows maybe his eyes dropped let
me just have class all right where'd the
bed for you but uh oh [ __ ] nice well
[ __ ] done Doug and a dork nonsense
might save a life who's to say it
already has it
his tongue it's so dry you're gonna take
notice but not enough okay we're gonna
have brick or something else pi threat
at a car right I can't reach that brick
okay let's see here let's see here
rather for the windows did you guys try
to get in there and get weapons I did
but it was too risky not a bunch of guys
showed up and they tried it what
happened I think they're most of whom
you see wandering around out there okay
let's see here let's see here like a
dude those things like TV or at least
the sound of it they were louder we
might be able to clear the street don't
turn that [ __ ] up
Doug you want to get this door open
about that you've got the cowboy right
no what did they want to ever have it
what man there were a lot of those
things trying to get in here and now we
can't get back out onto the street we're
also party to something great just fire
code violations I can't reach that brick
jay says as choose me that's not work I
was kidding universal but not that yours
I know Doug I think we got to go back
and set again what that's it back inside
okay you better get that cane to open up
the UM Shana
okay quick word on to shed and hand out
his shed
let's see here let's see here okay okay
get in my way Lily get on my nerves Lily
okay
I balls get a little dry
that's the door to the pharmacy we
should be able to find clothes valerian
there the keys are on that zombie out on
the street
there's nothing else here
come on dog there'll be something
kerala do you have the answers I'm gonna
keep looking around okay
mm-hmm
you're right we just talked to Carly
real quick then I guess looks like
nobody got a chance to donate anything
before this all went down Central High
take state papers a week Oh feels like
years what are you messing around with
their a radio I can't get it to work
though here let me have a look
hmm nothing
let's see here
AA batteries of this thing what now you
know that there are no batteries in that
thing yeah of course I mean ya know I
can try to find some leads to Thanks I
wouldn't even really know what to look
for don't have batteries okay now got
like [ __ ] 10 million things look for
this matter is that crazy see this
batteries around here battery is looking
for that bad raise ok good assassin aids
beverages newspaper Connie beings others
really
Oh
ok
this battery should fit the radio here
man thanks and no problem i'm still
looking for batteries for that day
thanks i appreciate it [ __ ] okay give
me a second me sick
perfumes family planning [ __ ] when the
[ __ ] batteries gonna be you gotta
check the office now it's got it circled
all day it's fine I like circles
luckily there's nothing I need in here
the pants came in here hoping to survive
looks like one of the most mundane to be
a hero maybe
protect our least mm-hmm [ __ ] are the
batteries
can I just like take their mode so that
that's what I figured
she ate a meal I could take out the
batteries now and i'll just talk filling
I guess
how's your thing it's okay thanks for
fixing it everyone up there seem all
right to you yeah well maybe not the
sick guy yeah we'll keep an eye on him
there was that thing in the bathroom he
tried to get me borrow but you stopped
it yeah yeah I was a year that right
more well I'm not gonna go looking for I
mean get the dangerous ones I'm gonna
try good
I'm gonna keep looking around okay yeah
yeah yeah I wasn't here you should talk
to her about that bucket okay let's
check in here check in here
big
what do you think about all the SH an
attractor to think the debtor up walking
around eating people and turning them
into more more of them ok [ __ ] jeez I
don't need the attitude right now stays
there's a apocalypse going on right now
I'm gonna get back to him so it's good I
don't want to leave that guy
maybe I have to you know
oh there it is it's the [ __ ] floor
okay
bad breeze ok here's another one should
be able to get it to work now it's still
not working yeah I can't figure it out
let me have a look at that thing go
ahead let's see it look at me i do it to
work you know like my man do at work she
put in him right or did she [ __ ] put
in backwards it's [ __ ] backwards
that's s
what shall continues to spread unchecked
the estimated death toll continues to
skyrocket wabe urges you to stay in
avoid any contact with individuals you
suspect may have been exposed the
station is okay you're a pretty good
shot well you don't [ __ ] with a reporter
especially one that's three days out
from her last cup of coffee can love to
kiss you
that radius I love didn't sound too good
are you okay I'm fine
you don't have to be it's dramatic ok
sir I'm sure some people got out maybe
they're all being rescued and you can
set a family you know
you
how we doing good want to go have a look
around outside yes let's have a look
around okay you gotta get that [ __ ] few
seconds of searching it we don't know if
he has the keys okay let's take a good
Gander a good Gander nothing on his
booty nothing on his birdie Jeffrey's
unbrick nothing here Xabi Xabi nothing
up there it's done what locks do
I've got a map that lock over there
imagine going out the back door and
around is out of the question we're
gonna help Larry we need to get this
lock off their shoes us uzhe have to
talk to him back every cent brick can
you reset Rick
how'd you end up here I moved here to
live with my uncle he does tech stuff
and it just made sense so your local you
probably knew the owners of this place
no no really I've only been here a
couple months and spend a lot of time on
the computer now just do
thing are you
I grew up here and trying to get home
since they came back oh so you probably
knew the honors then I do good people I
can't reach that breaker just
do you think we're safe here I haven't
been able to get through this gate so
far the drugs try to save another me
whoever owned it took the character flaw
Stockton walks up well okay okay
we break that lock off and I can get out
onto the street it's a combination lock
that's a hasty fortification job over
there yeah didn't work what is the
secret had a [ __ ] you get that brick
Sting's like TV at least sounded they
were louder we might be able to clear
the street those TVs are and I'm true
they're making a lot of noise behind a
glass how the heck getting over there
nope
Oh
bed
[ __ ] here
did you guys try to get in there and get
weapons I did but it was too risky and a
bunch of guys showed up and they lied
and what happened but and there was a
will be wandering around out there
do we have to keep funny Alex one mic in
there oh well Carly's pretty nice Lily
doesn't take any crap she's been running
field keeping people on launched
dan yeah that guy is kind of a dick
pardon my french
let me just say
now now now
alright [ __ ] it lets see it back inside
please [ __ ] go
then we got to proceed
hey Tommy
you ready to head out you got it you
yeah yeah let's go off that deep voice I
could just sing for days
each other guys been [ __ ] Papa Papa
papa
did you see that sword it'd be ready to
shoot kisshu glad you're here Jesus
Quinn right dead wasn't so hard can we
get out of here before any of these
things notice us not yet there's a
survivor trapped up there no way we
gotta go now listen I was out here
looking for gas and then up there in the
corner room I heard crying to move from
inside who is it it's a girl we talked
and she got frightened I was trying to
get in to help her and she started
yelling and saying I was bitten I tried
to convince her I wasn't and that's what
all these guys came out of the forest
look I've almost got me and I ended up
hiding in the ice machine lucky you now
let's go we can't just leave her damn
right we can you guys are suicidal over
a girl I'm saving her with or without
you we think solder the girls you fine
let's go save Glenn's damsel in distress
Glen lips those goofs ok that's it let's
see
okay okay this is the plan don't know
how hard it's gonna be to get her out of
that room yeah 1400 so we have to kill
every one of them in here quietly noise
attracts these things let's have a look
around
so we got that one right there close
the girls behind that door those two
seem to be on a set we can highlight by
that pickup I saw one working on the
other side of that car
we could hide by the RV you require to
keep our heads down oh [ __ ] oh good luck
smothering them to death that's not
really what I have in mind what do you
have in mind okay run [ __ ] run run run
[ __ ]
we're a little naked out here except for
Carly's gone and we can't use that much
okay see ya walk well I get one pillow
and two corpses you need your problem
well I got one pillow and two corpses
get your problem I'm not sure I can take
them both out myself even if I had a
weapon see what's over there
it's a factor that a wall st. there that
[ __ ]
okay brown patch rod
oh [ __ ] I wonder if there's anything in
the big girl oh well you would bass
mother I don't really know kidding his
have any tricks were getting into cars
it's breaking out doors making a bunch
of noise a number of pillows
pretty damn good way to stephanie's guys
quickly now we just have to get it
quietly see what else is here get out
your gun but the noise you just follow
my lead stay right behind me if they're
gonna use a pillow as a silencer of
those ridiculous there's no way that was
sick
Oh alarm please no alarm off thank god
oh yeah
hard luck you should hold on to that
could come in handy
kill them this is awesome okay I think
we'd use the spark plug that right let
me see the spark block it was exciting
strands calling I looks so evil yeah
that can scramble grain pretty good
that's exactly what I was thinking yes
get the [ __ ] out of here guys can't they
seconds that's it their hair age did not
know how fast that was oh Jesus sorry
about that guys hey everyone there
everyone makes mistakes get yourself
it's cool soccer well done your PlayBook
label plate yes I'll wait for him to get
closer oh that's not gonna work oh yes
yes
I like this I like this
just scary i love us like I guess you
lost that dude where'd you up and go
into the nice big size toll oh you it's
here now we've got this are you two done
wow what a guy two more gotcha
why don't you guys lag behind just in
case this goes to hell okay we'll be
right behind you she is hot as heck I
don't even know what she says these days
just look at her
hazy yes hey Cass looking yes that's
good those rats good all right just past
me gasps Jesus ok now let's see just get
this done we got an ax ok ladylike hello
in there and we're here to help we're
let's go guys in a minute if you open up
we can take you somewhere safer we've
got a group in town she's in trouble
miss we're coming in just hook watch you
spit television on Larry so funny that's
how me it doesn't
stop just stop um coming out hope she's
hotter than Italy oh yeah oh god I said
stay away we need to get you help it's
too late for that guys she's been bitten
what I told you I said go away I'm
bitching leave let's calm down it could
be fine I won't be fine my boyfriend was
bitten you get sick and you die and it
have you come back and you kill anything
you can find the kissa though you have a
boyfriend when I don't want that
Christian please just leave me please go
what if you turn and follow us back why
was he no that was why I was locked away
I kid what this happened to me you got a
Kelly you have a gun so and I borrow it
what do you mean borrow give it to me I
can just you know envis and then then
there's no problem whoa whoa whoa I
don't you talkin right say [ __ ] be
not and rip evan [ __ ] trappin give it
to her what is this public can't be
serious do it then shooter sure I see
what hell is like and it's coming back
as one of those things sook her help her
out here you're insane just take this
thing oh just shoot are you want the gun
thank you so much I know how terrible
this must be we can't watch this let's
go we can't please what why not because
somebody needs to pick up the gun can't
leave it
you two go on ok
come on [ __ ] has this do this I'm here
with you you are good man yes I guess
her kiss her kiss her yes
he's thinking by kissing her stuff he's
like it he's like should I uh oh she's
kissing oh I can't run
huh everyone on right yeah we had some
close calls but Glenn is spine and well
yeah we're okay I've got a few cans of
gas for your big up in the trunk of my
car now get gonna hear it and things
back here quiet our friend is still in
and out
you won't survive any more stress the
next order of business is getting those
pills out of the fire sounds the first
order but I
okay okay okay see what's now let's see
what's now nothing nothing
how are you doing good you know
any you know the combination for the
lock on the gate outside why oh you know
I thought I'd go stretch my legs you're
probably better off breaking it if you
have to
God
try to get some rest huh yeah right
okay that was not helpful let's see what
carrie has to say now hey there
story of the century here huh yeah and
I've got [ __ ] for recording equipment
and from the looks of it there isn't
going to be any shortage of first-hand
accounts you do radio that's right well
until some piece-of-shit politicians
yank our funding and I hit the
blogosphere I better get back to it yep
thanks by the way don't mention it just
remember what I said yeah Oh will oh
[ __ ] I still the ax I get I'll do it how
are we doing good want to go have a look
around outside let's have a look around
okay yes what's access peanut butter
awesome they got it we get a noise how
to distract those things Oh take it
carefully I can't reach that break are
you [ __ ] kidding me
okay what could break what's a break oh
the glass make it louder okay we got
this we got this
now's the time
raat sucker rod
why Pikachu the Ron why is he doing that
with you heck yeah yeah
kissa kissa kissa I don't know what
happened to mom and dad but I know if
you were there if you find them yet give
me a second side would need but no I
take you kissing kissing kissing is
begging for her
okay pretty intense or somewheres
Ayatollah okay now actually did he was
want to torture his brother beforehand
or I guess they just want the torture
and I yes uh yeah you [ __ ] made a
mess change this there we go holy crap
Ron
why did he yell that there's like no
let's go
ships are knocking right man that was
close but we did it solving matters uh
you [ __ ] butchered his brother what
the [ __ ] I've got the keys great the
tories e let's get in there
I got the pic eggs are fertilized
oh look at that oh okay oh we gotta
hurry 40 Stephanie I'd seen her in years
I said she done
yeah this is probably a great commercial
for genes like all the genes are holding
up so well only it out fabric is all my
stuff but yeah okay
every time to go I'm gonna get the truck
pulled up doing they said that guy can
cuddle your stress / galleon honey take
duck into the office and barricade the
living hell out of the door behind me
when would you hear me honking in the
alleys start getting people out of here
you got it Doug Carly and Lee you guys
make sure our defense to stay up till
then lead I'll better take that action
cuz I run into any one way to my truck
girl Gordon Lott Lock this bar [ __ ] you
three get on it I'll get back as fast as
I can away from the windows
are you sure
oh no this is insane
kept doing it because she's hotter cuz
he got to say what do you want yeah
let's go this is a shuttle you gotta
move yeah huh
oh no [ __ ] way
I'm not letting somebody else kitty
today especially I've ever [ __ ] that guy
up
wow those [ __ ] up oh well
I've gonna kill her because we're back
like kill that one girl yeah clean this
mess up lady yes
I'm going to [ __ ] that guy up I can't
believe I got met through an ungrateful
[ __ ] meanwhile inland Atlanta's been
downgraded temporarily to an e glad
let's [ __ ] it's sad
that cheese
Bertha County Georgia cities in their
current level of disaster are as follows
Atlanta stage 9 catastrophe a gutta the
intended to town to woodland yeah I got
friends then I just can't stay here
knowing that they could be trapped in
that city sounds like nobody knows
what's happening when we left a few days
ago could have gone either way I gotta
take my chances
oh she went to kiss me one else not a
good time I said later I'll kiss you
later you gotta do what you gotta do and
I gotta do this I'll respect her you
guys be safe one brother to another you
know if this doesn't get better people
are going to give up uh give me that
radio back there are you just gonna let
them you told Carly to get her the gun
yeah but dude maybe you were right I
don't know how to hit something like
that anyway see you around let's jump
lekha I could too yeah I did it yeah
peace brother respect you bring the gang
and click in spirit whoever you
I see him no no contact thank you [ __ ]
close call back there thanks for picking
me up no problem we have to take care of
each other yeah we do hey I limit that
on Clementine yeah earlier I said
there's some stuff out there that might
screw up a precious little girl like you
did well I still think that's true but
after what I saw today boys that thing
between you taking care of her and her
taking care of herself he's voice actor
to we're gonna be just fine love me I
sleep any day like you got dancing you
do audiobooks oh nice jacket well I
don't talk that lady no I today oh yeah
I saved you how are you doing curbing
I'm okay you know considering i do and i
can't stop thinking about Doug I
couldn't have saved him could we [ __ ]
we saved you happen proof is I get it I
know it's stupid we just met and he was
such a it's just that I think that I
liked him
well I'm sorry like you too you better
have any way I'd rather be alone I think
i'ma stay i get i did we rockin lee i
think it was in the hero tell me I'm a
hero how did you choose we both needed
you you're hotter it's me i was gonna
help you both but you helped me first
yeah i did i just wish we both could
have made it you know me to Carly who do
you have to tell her I didn't have to
tell her heck out picked area just in
case we gotta hate I'll start species
again Jesus you know I just got tough me
feel--first duck it's only my god super
dinosaur was a toast but you know what
he wasn't oh and dad duck you want to
cool it for a minute that's right sorry
I'm sorry there's not a lot of kids here
no it's not that it's I got grabbed
again I was there though I felt and my
walkie-talkie broke Glenn had the other
one it's just a walkie-talkie it
probably wasn't much used to begin with
it wasn't just a walkie-talkie I know it
doesn't make any sense but it's how are
you stalking I'm here to God you get up
Sorry Sorry gonna talking to a cab if I
do another one I'll just keep this one
and a guess Lee come here for a second
Bob follow me he'll deal with this I'm
gonna [ __ ] this [ __ ] up this [ __ ] is
gonna be praying what do you want you
like my daughter
yeah she's great well stay the [ __ ] away
from oh I'm or what [ __ ] aura everyone
will know that you Lee Everett are a
killer and you were before it was
something you had to do to stay alive
I'm gonna [ __ ] this [ __ ] up I'm gonna
[ __ ] did I know who you are and I don't
give a [ __ ] about what happens to you
but if anything happens to my daughter
or that little girl you've got with you
you watch your ass I oh my god I'm gonna
[ __ ] that [ __ ] up where's it going do
you have a second oh [ __ ] I hey [ __ ]
just to [ __ ] him my dad would be dead if
it weren't for you that guy doug is dead
because of me you can't be like that
you're only one man we're lucky to have
you
hope that's the sound of us winning this
thing me too this motor Inns pretty damn
defendable we block off the entrances
with some cars I can't wanton watch
can't even stay here until the military
thing is i need to get my revenge i
actually agree with that plan me too we
got beds we got water and most
importantly we got light your worst
places to call home
[ __ ] that guy I'm gonna [ __ ] this dude
at least a start i thought that guy up
all right adios muchachos not a yes oh
wait let's just see what's on here it
seems on here
I thought would be fine if we survive
the waters never expected it starve us
out
I want you to have this okay in case
your Clementine starts feeling weak you
don't owe me anything how you doing good
time I'm really hungry Lee we gotta get
food Lee soon howdy I'm Andrew st. John
we're from the st. John Derry it's
beautiful I never did thank you for
saving duck from the walkers back at
Herschel's farm something's coming Lee
there's gonna be more the walkers don't
worry babies
happening no please no more please okay
honesty like the Herschel I'm good good
give Irene oh so we were in the minority
to give Irene the gods gun you see
better Carly I don't less people so
Carlo i sexist I'm not all right well I
am hope you guys enjoyed it I hope you
guys enjoyed it
tell ya part two is coming ooping of our
charming episode 2 so I hope y'all enjoy
seconds yes